meu deus tá parecendo um zumbi a todo o
vídeo do colhido na água mas esse fé dá
me matando a água nem muito agora não
pode tem grave porque a todo dia e aí a
regional foram vocês sabem há muito
tempo que nossos televisão que eu não
joguei videogame que aí eu mudei isso
não vê que está passando então passa a
novela então só que eu acho muito
estranho 90 por exemplo as crianças de
novela elas têm um negócio que não tendo
chegado às salas chega da escola e ela
sob um sofá de tênis o que não faz
sentir nenhum na minha casa se eu
colocar os pés em cima do sofá e
falência múltipla dos órgãos na hora
outra colocou a sua estante na novela
tem uma criança menino esse menino se
chama paulin paulo tem 14 anos paulinho
com sua 8ª série do ensino fundamental
que paulo tem duas vezes a minha altura
tem barba e amanhã enfim anabolizante no
útero neve durante a gestação porque ele
é grande forte e sexos e que faz novela
não faz escala por favor por favor não
faz isso assume da depressão do eu tenho
19 anos tem um pingo de barba outra no
próximo mês em média é o seguinte
absoluta na casa dela é alguém bate na
porta um dia normal da vida dela vai
abrir a porta vai abrir a porta e foi
assim
você é meu deus que é que abra a porta
ou é uma pessoa que fala assim eu sei
que a pessoa que você gosta ou beleza e
metais e quinta feira a pessoa que não
gosta de fechar a porta do pronto fica
não fica você encontra quando a gente é
novela mexicana que novela mexicana
engraçado porque tudo é tudo tudo tudo
tudo tudo bem ensaiado a impressão de
que a vida do mexicano um teatro tá
ligado à bem e faz um bom dia a jogar é
como bom dia eles vão embora como os
bonecos e novela mexicana eu acho que é
o que tem de mais diferente da vida real
já que a diferença da novela mexicana a
vida real não vejo a hora do meu filho
nascer este que está em 90 e será o
herdeiro da família
o dono da empresa de toda a família
nunes em mudar a história deste país
como todos os dias a minha santinha de
guadalupe para guiar o meu filho vai
nascer mandou mandar na vida real
só que com chuva voltou a reinar casa
fechada de casa não me ajuda em nada
quero que jogos na seca colocam a baixar
na boca de família é uma coisa que
preste da malhação tem k fez o mal amada
desclassificada tá falando isso que seus
pais não podem pagar o seu estudo é não
encheu o saco cheio da vida real
brincar brincar pai
chega com eles quatro machos hoje
gostaria muito que você comente aqui
embaixo que você acha mais estranho e
novela 21 danny maccabee que ter sair
daqui sem clicando nos tenho meu deus
não posso crer não posso acreditar senão
teria coragem de sair daqui
sempre gostei por favor não faça ter que
enviar esse cabo de vassoura inteiro
dentro do seu curso é a primeira vez que
estava no vídeo meu só porque a
inscrever-se que todo este ano novo você
vai saber que eu queria que você está
curtindo a minha fã page no facebook a
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo logo
depois tem o twitter o instagram e tem o
meu perfil também no facebook então
valeu é nice e dan é isso aí valeu
o